let's answer some audience questions
first one from Lucas is astrology
harmful or just innocent fun there was a
time when astrology and astronomy both
had more of a basis in observable fact I
guess but as we know there has been a
very significant divergence and
astrology is the non-science of the
positioning of celestial bodies and the
positioning of celestial bodies when
people were born as being influencers of
that person's personality disposition
ability to get along with people born at
other times of the year etc that's
generally how I describe astrology right
it sounds like a very legitimate term
astrology would be what the study of
stars yes and it's not I don't think
that it's harmful I mean I think for the
most part like you read your horoscope
we know that there's huge confirmation
bias if you if you mix up horoscopes so
that like the aquarius horoscope which
would be mine has been replaced with the
scorpio if i read it believing it's the
Aquarius one if I want to see truth in
it I will see truth in it okay because
they're generally pretty vaguely worded
yes so they'll say something like you
are very hard working well hard-working
to me anything it could be in your in
your personal life at work at the gym
and your hobbies you could get hard
working at video games or every wanted
to pay respect anticipate a week with
both triumphs and difficulty that
applies to most people right i mean okay
so anyway that's the point i think it's
absolutely and completely bogus i
generally don't think that it is harmful
except and i know people who believe in
it some to such a degree that they will
actually avoid signing certain contracts
or doing certain errands like that might
be I don't know the processing of bills
for example on days where they've
identified that something about the
positioning of stars planets or other
celestial bodies is at odds with what
they believe is good for them based on
their astrological sign
I don't think that that's necessarily
harmful but it actually could be and
it's just a total disconnection from
what we know of as science-based
understandings of the world around us
and you could argue that that's harmful
nonsense right you can't base your life
and the events in it on something that
you can't prove and also just something
that's arbitrary like the lining of the
stars I mean what actual impact does
that have on you did you ever would you
ever regularly read your horoscope out
regularly i mean i would check it out
every now and then if i see it in the
paper love it I remember as a kid I
would read the comics in the paper and
for whatever reason I can't think of why
the horoscopes were on the same page as
the comics interestingly enough so i
would check it out i would see what does
it say for Aquarius and yeah I mean it's
cool look at the names Aquarius cancer
Gemma and I I mean I'm hooked already on
it yeah so you think that the marketing
around astrology makes it really
appealing because they have these names
or people say wow I am a Leo I am Leo
the Lion let's see what my horoscope is
and it's something yet to check out
every day so people keep coming back to
it it's great market and it's
interesting that's that I never thought
about the marketing aspect of it you've
got to keep getting your horoscope yeah
I think it's completely bogus I think in
most cases it's innocent fun or
distraction but I've seen cases where it
can actually be harmful